about a week ago I got on a train with
Charlie McDonnell we went through
Swindon Town it was raining and the
doors the Train scared me because you
didn't have to touch them when I asked
Charlie if he wanted to hang out while
we were in the UK he said he wanted to
take us to Bath a city of 80,000 people
that was declared by UNESCO in its
entirety to be a World Heritage Site so
yeah I guess it's the World Heritage
build-a-bear there and a world heritage
Pizza Hut it is a world heritage Abbey
it's pretty nice Abbey I asked Charlie
about the bath Abbey
it's painted in an episode of community
indeed we have lunch with Charlie's mom
we talked about inequity and happiness
and she drove us on the wrong side of
the road up a hill so that we can get a
nice view of Bath honestly I should be
saying baths here because every time I
had bath people had no idea what is
talking about the view was indeed nice
though then Charlie walked us down
pulse-width slippery path all time very
dangerous and down to the river which
was gorgeous than of a hill past a bunch
of fancy nineteenth-century houses and
to the Royal present then back down to
the baths which is what bath was named
for the Roman baths constructed nearly
2,000 years ago and still able to hold
water they are it made of lead though so
don't drink it that's hot spring made it
one of the principal resources of the
Roman occupation of Britain the Romans
built what was probably the largest
structure in England around the spring
converting it into kind of tourist
attraction for wealthy Romans that was
in continuous use for hundreds of years
so long that their wooden shoes wore
through the stone floors wealthy Romans
would come for relaxation for prayer and
to show off how rich they were who could
afford more attendance more luxurious
scented oils that kind of thing the more
things change the more they stay the
same right to the baths were used by all
kinds people would inscribe curses on
pieces of pewter and then throw them
into the baths with notes like I think
Jeff stole my gloves could you please
burn his eyes out of his Edie please
it's got a beautiful to see how petty
and silly we were then in the context of
how petty and silly we continue to be
there's a wonder to that and to our
continued existence despite it the Roman
baths and the ADI and the Royal Crescent
and even the Marks and Spencer all those
things in many ways are monuments to
wealth sure they take different forms
housing religion relaxation shopping but
they're all a display of the very
excesses that we right
Phillie complain about today income
inequality concentration of wealth
frivolous spending the Roman Baths after
all were built by the enslaved survivors
of a war of conquest but in a way that's
why we enjoyed them today they are
exceptional now because they were
exceptional then and they were
exceptional then because only a
concentration of wealth and power made
them possible most of the things that we
tend to observe from our cultural
history are artifacts of concentrated
wealth and the greatest and most enjoyed
objects of our age will likely be as
well whether we're talking about the
Burj Khalifa or the iPhone or the Harry
Potter movies are the Hubble Space
Telescope were extremely expensive and
all of them required a humongous
concentration of the world's wealth
mostly it has to be said here in America
we talk a lot about the crazy income
inequality within America but globally
that's a much more upsetting picture to
be in the richest 1% of the world you
need to make a whopping thirty five
thousand dollars per year if you have
two thousand dollars in the bank you're
richer than half the world we have to
take notice of the amazing creations of
our own age and consider what the
greatest cultural legacy would be the
answer of course being peace and plenty
and equality and awesome Charlie thanks
for taking me around bath John I'll see
you on Tuesday